Democratic senator Amy Klobuchar of
Minnesota joins us from Washington she
is a member of the Judiciary Committee
and a former prosecutor senator good
morning thank you so much for joining us
thanks Nora it's great you heard judge
Cavanaugh say that he has never sexually
assaulted anyone not in high school not
ever he also said he has never been so
drunk that he didn't remember the night
before
do you believe Judge Cavanaugh is lying
I have in front of me several witnesses
people who are coming forward that want
to have a chance to make their case to
the American people to make their case
to the Senate and I think we need to
give them the opportunity to do that and
there are a few things that he said in
that interview that I really keyed in on
the first was that he said that he
wanted a fair process and to me that
obviously means allowing for some
limited investigations a background
information check where you simply go
and you check with the people that these
women said were there and it is a lot
different to have to be interviewed by
an FBI agent I'm under oath basically
than it is when you're just talking
print perhaps to a reporter off the
record and the second thing about that
interview was when he said that he
actually downplayed his drinking and he
said he never really blacked out so he
didn't remember things I mean those are
things that really go to credibility
given some of the stories circulating
out there and again even in the Anita
Hill hearing Norah we had dozens of
witnesses that came forward and were
allowed to testify this time all of
that's being shut out and as a former
prosecutor I think you have to be able
to at least get the facts down I think
it's important no matter what side
you're on on this if you want him or you
don't want him don't you want to have
the facts we ask you this because in the
case with dr. Ford as well as even
Deborah Ramirez I mean how do you
evaluate these accusations when there is
essentially no contemporaneous evidence
well first of all you look at things
that you would in any kind of a case or
a proceeding you look at the fact that
she came forward and talked about this
before judge Cavanaugh was even famous
so he was on the DC Circuit but I don't
think many people could name one judge
on there
except maybe Merrick garland but there
there she was coming forward to a
marriage counselor saying that this had
happened to her I think that's
interesting because she didn't really
have a motivation to make that up and
then in other cases you would also look
at what did the other witnesses say and
in this case we're being shut out for
getting that information things that
haven't happened in past hearings when
major things have come forward the White
House has asked the FBI like in the
Anita Hill States to reopen the
investigation senator the Republicans
heard me are thinking about having an
experienced sex crimes prosecutor do the
questioning given the sensitivity given
that everybody wants to get to the
bottom this isn't that a good idea John
you know this isn't a criminal trial and
when you look through history you have
senators who represent their
constituents asking questions and that
is how we plan to do this on our side
the way it's always been done they're
looking at and I believe a lot of it has
to do is that they have only men on
their side they have 11 men I said the
other day that old movie 12 Angry Men
this is instead 11 men try not to look
angry by having a woman do their work
and I don't understand why they wouldn't
just have one or two of their own
senators many of whom have had vast
experience in criminal justice ask those
questions senator could we talk about
rod Rose inside for just a second his
position appears to be a little tenuous
today are you concerned about the
meeting on Thursday that he may be fired
or may resigned I'm very concerned this
is a man that is number two in the
Justice Department overseeing a national
security investigation the Muller
investigation about whether a foreign
country cyber attacked our own country
sometimes people call it meddling I
think that's what I do when I call my
daughter on a Saturday night and ask her
what she's doing this is an actual cyber
attack and for the president to be
looking at getting rid of this person I
think is absolutely outrageous he's
someone that served under Democratic and
Republican president and it's very
important that we keep him in place
protect the investigation that's why a
number of us are saying let's bring that
Special Counsel bill that passed through
bipartisan judiciary come
all right well bring it to the floor
protect this investigation all right
senator we'll have to leave it there
thank you so much senator Thank You
Gayle Thank You Norah thanks John
CBS News will bring you live
gavel-to-gavel coverage of the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearings beginning
Thursday at 10:00 a.m. Eastern 9:00
central